i want to share with you
the number one best food
for toxic kidneys in order to understand
that i have to give you a little
background information but the big
problem when you're diagnosed with
kidney disease especially if it's end
stage kidney disease
is that they don't really have any good
solutions that give you a good prognosis
you know they might say well you have to
get kidney dialysis you know and that's
just terrible terrible to go through
that and the prognosis from that is just
not good they're not giving you any
natural solutions
the thing with the kidney is that it's a
filter so any drugs that they give you
is going to be more toxicity to the
kidney so when we're dealing with a
damaged filter we need to use something
natural that has virtually no side
effects
so this kidney filters out chemicals
pesticides insecticides herbicides
fungicides heavy metals plastics
excess minerals it recycles a lot of
things too it's very very efficient it
gets rid of excess sugar and of course
if you're eating a lot of sugar it
destroys the filter because diabetes is
the number one cause of
kidney disease
it also gets rid of excess protein
byproducts so when we eat protein and
that breaks down it goes to a chain
reaction of things
that
end up with ammonia which is very very
toxic to several parts of the body
especially the neurons in your brain and
this is why if someone has too much
ammonia that goes up into the brain
because it's too much in the blood they
can end up with
dementia
all sorts of really terrible things
normally what happens is the body has
this urea cycle where this protein that
turns into ammonia then turns into a
lesser toxic thing called urea and
that's supposed to be
you know excreted through the urine and
so the liver is also involved in this
process as well and if you have a really
toxic kidney
chances are you also have a toxic liver
because they work closely together
unfortunately you are swimming in a sea
of toxicity our environment i mean
there's over a thousand new chemical
compounds
created every single
hour okay so we're just getting hit from
every different angle so we need healthy
kidneys we need healthy liver
to deal with all this toxicity also the
kidney is the main organ
that helps activate vitamin d
the liver is involved too but the kidney
is even more important in the conversion
of the inactive d
to the active form of vitamin d and you
know how important d is and like i said
before diabetes is one of the main
big causes of kidney disease so what are
the symptoms of toxic kidneys okay well
you can have gout
which is uric acid building up usually
in your
the joint of your big toe and that
mainly occurs because the kidney is not
able to get rid of
this uric acid effectively
kidney stones where you have this super
concentrated
calcium oxalate stone that develops in
the kidney you can prevent stones by
consuming enough liquids so we don't
have this super concentrated
solution
puffy eyes you can look at someone's
face and just look around their eyes
and you can see kidney problems so if
it's puffy especially underneath and on
top
usually they have kidney issues because
the fluids backing up they also have
edema in their lower ankles when you
press on the lower ankle it leaves an
indentation they might have itchy skin
they might have glucose in the urine or
protein in the urine their urine might
smell very very strong of ammonia and
like i said before if the kidney was
doing its job you would just have urea
but if there's too much ammonia this
whole breakdown process is not occurring
because the kidney is damaged
and ammonia like i said before is very
very toxic to the brain your urine might
look very very dark and foamy that
usually means that this filter is not
filtering just like if you were to
change the oil filter in your car if you
haven't changed it for for a couple
years it's going to be really really
dark and filled with all sorts of things
now the foamy part is usually too much
protein in the urine because it's not
being recycled properly
and you may even experience high blood
pressure
okay so now the question is what is the
best food out of all the foods
that can support toxic kidneys and i
looked at what the kidney is supposed to
do what occurs when you have toxicity in
your kidneys
and this is what i came up with right
here
bok choy
now why would bok choy
be the number one food well first of all
it is a cruciferous vegetable
and that means that it has enzymes to
help with something called phase two
detoxification now since we're trying to
detoxify poisons from the body consuming
more cruciferous is going to help you in
that process because it takes these
poisons and it turns into harmless
particles so it takes the stress off
the kidney number two it's high in
potassium potassium is very protective
to the kidney a lot of times people will
say well you need to avoid sodium
no you need to increase potassium
because potassium is a mineral it's very
protective it's also high in magnesium
which is also protective
and the thing about bok choy is it has
no oxalates like things like almonds and
spinach and a lot of other vegetables
and legumes and beans and grains and
things like that they're high in
oxalates and eating too many foods with
oxalates could cause you to create
kidney stones so it's low in oxalates
and it's low in protein so if you have
protein in the urine
you don't want to be consuming a lot of
protein why because it's going through
you want to consume less protein but
just higher quality
protein but with bok choy it hits all
the different factors
so you can just steam it put some garlic
on it maybe a little sea salt and it's
actually quite healthy
all right number two
consume apple cider vinegar with some
water okay through the day what is that
gonna do the acetic acid in apple cider
vinegar is kidney protective it'll help
you okay it will also help your blood
sugars which again is the
big cause of kidney problems in the
first place and of course i didn't
mention this but you would definitely
want to get on the ketogenic diet and do
fasting for sure okay lemon juice why
because lemon juice has citric acid and
that can reduce
the risk of getting stones
also lemon juice even though it's an
acid turns into an alkaline solution in
your body
and that can help with gout too because
any time when you have these uric acid
crystals that are depositing into the
joint if you alkalize the body a little
bit
it'll stop that process
okay
celery juice or just celery by itself
okay it decreases ammonia and urea it
helps detoxify this ammonia and it helps
decrease the risk of
stones
number five lower the amount of protein
like i just mentioned to about three
ounces of protein per meal especially if
your protein is high in your urine all
right number six make sure your diet is
high in potassium you need big salads
small to moderate protein huge salads no
grains or sugars or anything like that
but a high potassium diet would be
protective
to the kidney like i said before it's
not about lowering your sodium because
you need certain amounts of sodium and
chloride but it's you really need the
ratios correct so we usually need to
increase the potassium and not really
touch the sodium
distilled water is water without the
minerals and the other chemicals when
you consume distilled water it can help
detoxify
a lot of poisons
in your body it pulls things out that
way you can take the minerals that you
really need without the minerals that
you don't want like excessive amounts of
things like calcium
and things like that so distilled water
is really good for
kidney stones it's good for gout and
toxicity in general like the worst thing
you can do is to drink tap water when
you have bad kidneys because there's so
many chemicals fluoride and chloride and
all sorts of things now number eight
probiotics
your gut contributes to making ammonia
so if you were to just consume
either foods with probiotics like kimchi
or sauerkraut or take a probiotic that
could take some of the load off the
kidney okay same thing with the liver
you could take like milk thistle that
would be a good thing to do to take more
stress off the kidney
zinc has been known to decrease ammonia
and urea in the urine so just make sure
you have enough zinc in the diet
and lastly there's a great
product
by a company called standard processed
is called arginx i'm not affiliated with
that company but this product is
something i used to use in practice
arginx is basically arginase which is an
enzyme that helps convert some of this
byproduct of protein into something that
you can get rid of so it's great to
detoxify the kidney and especially the
biochemistry that occurs at the end of
this
urea cycle okay so arginx is really good
for gout it's good for kidney stones
it's good for toxicity in the kidney and
you would take a good amount of this
per day so you can look it up stand a
process and order it now before you go i
have some exciting news i finally after
many many months actually probably took
us a year we finally upgraded our new dr
berg app that you can download for free
and this will allow you to carry me
around with you so anytime you have a
question you want to do some research on
a topic you'll be able to get access to
all my videos because you'll have the
app on your cell phone